>>> YOU ARE LIVE IN THE "CNN
NEWSROOM."
I'M JIM ACOSTA IN WASHINGTON.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
DROPPING HIS BIGGEST HINTS YET
HE PLANS TO RUN IN 2024.
HIS RALLY IN IOWA LAST NIGHT
FEELING A WHOLE LOT LIKE THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
HE'S TEASING A NEW SLOGAN "MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, AGAIN," AND
OF COURSE RE-IMAGINING THE 2020
ELECTION IN ONLY A WAY HE CAN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, HE DIDN'T GET
ELECTED.
OKAY, FORGET THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SOME PEOPLE SAID, OH, SIR, IT
WAS COVID.
HILLARY CONCEDED.
I NEVER CONCEDED, NEVER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WHEN YOU HEAR THESE NUMBERS OF
SWING STATES, THERE WAS NO
REASON TO CONCEDE.
NO PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE HAS
EVER LOST AN ELECTION WHILE
WINNING FLORIDA, OHIO, AND A
PLACE CALLED IOWA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FIRST TIME IT'S EVER HAPPENED.
>> HE SAYS HE NEVER CONCEDED.
THAT'S, IN PART, BECAUSE HE IS
CONCEDED IN ADDITION TO BEING
DILUDED.
>> IT'S THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ISSUE, THE ISSUE THAT GETS THE
MOST PULL, THE MOST RESPECT.
THE BIGGEST CHEERS IS TALKING
ABOUT THE ELECTION FRAUD OF THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
NOBODY'S EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
>> SO EHE JUST GAVE AWAY THE BIG
LIE.
HE IS ADMITTING THAT HIS
ELECTION LIES ARE EGO JUICE,
JUST THERE TO PUMP UP THE CROWD,
THE VERY STUFF THAT FUELED THE
INSURRECTION.
AND BY NOW WE KNOW HE'LL TAKE
THOSE CROCODILE TEARS, THE BIG
LIE IS THE BIG CRY OF COURSE AS
WE SAID BEFORE, ALL THE WAY TO
THE BANK AND PERHAPS TO THE 2024
ELECTION.
FOR MORE ON THIS I'M JOINED BY
CNN POLITICAL ANALYST JOHN AVLON
AND CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
AND HOST OF PBS FIRING LINE
MARGARET HOOVER.
GUYS, THANKS, AS ALWAYS, FOR
BEING WITH US.
TRUMP'S 2024 TEASES ARE
BEGINNING TO FEEL LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK.
I GUESS THEY JUST HAPPEN OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY NEVER REALLY COME TO
FRUITION.
BUT THIS MAY ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
HE IS SOUNDING MORE AND MORE
LIKE A CONTENDER DESPITE, YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THOSE LIES THAT HE
TELLS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> JIM, HE'S IN IT TO WIN IT.
LET'S NOT FOOL OURSELVES.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS --
>> MAYBE NOT WIN IT.
>> WELL, AS WE KNOW, HE'LL PLAN
THAT HE WON IT EVEN IF HE
DIDN'T.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
SERIOUS POINT BECAUSE THERE ARE
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS WHO STILL
LOOK ME IN THE EYE, SERIOUS
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
OFFICEHOLDERS WHO SAY HE'S NOT
GOING TO RUN, AND THEY HAVE SOME
KIND OF JUSTIFICATION.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE
THING HE SAYS AND EVERY SINGLE
THING HE'S DOING, WHICH INCLUDES
PUTTING THE TEAM BACK TOGETHER
AND HAVING HIS PACT GOING AND
BASICALLY SAYING EVERYTHING HE
CAN LEGALLY WITHOUT TRIGGERING A
CAMPAIGN VIOLATION, HE HAS SAID
THAT HE'S RUNNING.
SO YOU GOT TO TAKE HIM FOR HIS
WORD.
THIS MAN IS RUNNING AND HE STILL
RUNS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
REPUBLICANS NEED TO GET THEIR
HEAD OUT OF THE SAND AND START
DEALING WITH IT.
>> YEAH, OUT OF SOMETHING, THE
SAND OR OTHER PLACES.
>> AS I SAID IN THE REALITY
CHECK LAST WEEK, THE SYMBOL OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY SHOULD NO
LONGER BE THE ELEPHANT, IT
SHOULD BE THE OSTRICH.
BUT THE REALITY, OF COURSE, IS
THAT IT'S DEADLY SERIOUS.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THAT PEOPLE
ARE IN DENIAL ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
RUNNING.
IT'S ALL ABOUT REPUBLICANS WHOSE
SILENCE IS EFFECTIVELY
COMPLICITY IN THIS EFFORT TO
OVERTURN AN ELECTION.
BECAUSE, LOOK, IF TRYING TO
OVERTURN AN ELECTION ISN'T
WRONG, ISN'T DISQUALIFYING?
NOTHING IS.
AND EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN WHO
STOOD ON THE STAGE WITH DONALD
TRUMP THAT NIGHT IS COMPLICIT,
OUT OF FEAR, OUT OF A DESIRE TO
GET SOME BENEFIT FROM HIS BASE.
THEY ARE COMPLICIT IN AN EFFORT
TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION AND TO
HAVE THAT CANCER METASTASIZE
ITSELF IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND THE REPUBLIC ITSELF, WHICH
IS WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> AND THEY'RE NORMALIZING WHAT
HE DID AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION
IN THE RUN-UP TO JANUARY 6th.
THEY ARE NORMALIZING IT AND
SANITIZING IT BY BEING UP ON
THAT STAGE WITH HIM.
AND THE FACT THAT HE GOES OUT
AND BLURTS OUT IN FRONT OF THE
CROWD THAT, OH, BY THE WAY, WHEN
I TALK ABOUT THIS ELECTION
STUFF, THAT'S WHAT GETS MOST OF
YOU GUYS ALL FIRED UP.
HE'S JUST OUT THERE ADMITTING
WHAT HE'S DOING HERE.
BUT SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL HAS
BECOME, THIS WAS THE OTHER THING
THAT JUST STOOD OUT TO ME LAST
NIGHT, HAS BECOME ONE OF TRUMP'S
GO-TO TARGETS.
HERE IS TRUMP ATTACKING MITCH
McCONNELL AGAIN LAST NIGHT.
>> MITCH McCONNELL DIDN'T HAVE
THE COURAGE TO CHALLENGE THE
ELECTION.
HE'S ONLY A LEADER BECAUSE HE
RAISES A LOT OF MONEY AND HE
GIVES IT TO SENATORS.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING HE'S GOT.
THAT'S HIS ONLY FORM OF
LEADERSHIP.
HE SHOULD'VE CHALLENGED THE
ELECTION.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT,
MARGARET?
>> JIM, THE ONLY THING MITCH
McCONNELL DIDN'T HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO WAS TO ENCOURAGE
HIS REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE TO
ACTUALLY VOTE TO CONVICT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD WAY MORE THAN
TEN.
THEY WERE READY TO GO.
AND IF THEY HAD HAD THE COURAGE
TO DO IT, DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT
BE ON A STAGE RIGHT NOW NAMING
HIM IN INFAMY.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT BE A
THREAT TO THE REPUBLIC.
THAT WAS MITCH McCONNELL.
IT WAS IN MITCH McCONNELL'S
HANDS, AND INSTEAD WE SENT HIM
TO ELBA.
THAT'S A NAPOLEON CONFERENCE,
AND HE'S COMING BACK.
>> SUCH AN IMPORTANT POINT
BECAUSE McCONNELL TRIED TO WALK
THAT LINE.
HE KNEW WHAT TRUMP DID WAS
WRONG.
HE HAD THE COURAGE TO CONDEMN
DONALD TRUMP BUT NOT TO TAKE THE
FINAL STEP THAT COULD HAVE
DISQUALIFIED HIM FOR FUTURE
OFFICE UNDER THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT SECTION 3.
AND BY PULLING THAT PUNCH AND
STILL TRYING TO PLAY FOOTSIE
WITH THE FANATICS IN THE PARTY,
THEY ARE DEALING WITH THE
CONDITIONS THAT THEY ARE NOW.
>> AND WE STILL HAVE THESE
HIGH-RANKING REPUBLICANS
CLINGING TO THIS IDEA THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S VICTORY WAS
ILLEGITIMATE, OR AT LEAST
FUELING THAT BELIEF INSIDE THE
REPUBLICAN BASE.
AND MAYBE YOU SAW THIS EARLIER
TODAY.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE, THE
NUMBER TWO HOUSE REPUBLICAN
EARLIER THIS MORNING.
LET'S WATCH.
IT'S PAINFUL TO WATCH, BUT LET'S
WATCH.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, ARE WE
GOING TO FOLLOW WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS OR NOT?
I HOPE WE GET BACK TO WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
BUT CLEARLY IN A NUMBER OF
STATES THEY DIDN'T FOLLOW THOSE
LEGISLATIVELY.
>> SO YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN?
>> WHAT I SAID IS THERE ARE
STATES THAT DIDN'T FOLLOW THEIR
LEGISLATIVELY SET RULES.
THAT'S WHAT THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION SAYS.
>> DO YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN OR NOT?
I UNDERSTAND YOU THINK THERE
WERE IRREGULARITIES AND THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE FIXED.
DO YOU THINK THE ELECTION IS
STOLEN?
>> IT'S STATES THAT DID NOT
FOLLOW THE LAWS SET, WHICH THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW.
>> IT'S JUST PHONY BOLOGNA
NONSENSE.
>> IT'S MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
TRYING TO UNDERCUT AND UNDO THE
CONSTITUTION IS DISGUSTING.
IT'S PATHETIC.
SCALISE KNOWS BETTER AND HE'S A
COWARD FOR NOT BEING WILLING TO
SAY IT.
>> WHAT SCALISE IS DOING THOUGH,
JIM, LET'S NOT LOSE THE LESSON,
SCALISE IS REPRESENTING THE
VIEWS OF REPUBLICAN PRIMARY,
SELF-IDENTIFIED REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY VOTERS WHO I HAVE SEEN
IN FOCUS GROUP AFTER FOCUS GROUP
SAY THERE WERE PROBABLY VOTING
IRREGULARITIES.
AND THEY START TO USE THE TERM
THE CONSTITUTION AND UNDERMINING
THE CONSTITUTION AS SHORTHAND
FOR SOMETHING THAT WAS UNFAIR TO
DONALD TRUMP.
AND SO WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION.
BUT THIS IS WHAT A SOLID PART OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE BASE
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
BELIEVES.
AND SO THAT ALSO HAS TO BE
FACTORED IN AS WE DEAL WITH THE
VERY REAL PROSPECT THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS COMING BACK.
AND IF YOU WANT TO WIN AT THE
BALLOT BOX, YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HIS VOTERS ARE
THINKING IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A PRAYER AT TRYING TO PERSUADE
SOME OF THEM NOT TO TURN OUT TO
VOTE.
>> AND ALL THEY DO IS PROJECT
THE TERM OF THEY'RE GUILTY OF
THE OTHER GUY.
IT'S PROJECT AND REFLECT.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS,
GUYS.
BECAUSE LAST NIGHT I SPOKE WITH
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER HARRY
DUNN WHO COULD BE A NICER,
SWEETER GUY.
HE IS A GREAT GUY.
I ASKED HIM ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE
TUCKER CARLSON WHO ARE STILL
PORTRAYING THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK AS SOME SORT OF PEACEFUL
EVENT WITH TOURISTS.
THAT IS SO APPALLING.
I'LL PUT THAT TO THE SIDE FOR A
MOMENT.
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT OFFICER DUNN
HAD TO SAY.
>> WHEN THEY SAW THAT CLIP, HOW
DID THEY GET INTO THAT CAPITOL?
HOW'D THEY GET IN THERE?
WE DIDN'T JUST LET THEM IN.
IT WAS A FIGHT.
THEY FOUGHT THEIR WAY THROUGH
LAYERS AND LAYERS OF SECURITY TO
GET THERE.
IT'S COINCIDENTAL THAT THEY JUST
SHOW THAT PARTICULAR FOOTAGE.
SHOW THE FOOTAGE LEADING UP TO
THAT.
HOW ABOUT THAT, THAT CLIPPED
THAT YOU JUST SHOWED, THEM
SPRAYING US AND FIGHTING US AND
HITTING US WITH POLES.
SHOW THAT CLIP.
WHAT DO YOU GOT TO SAY ABOUT
THAT?
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY'RE NOT
SHOWING THAT ON FOX?
>> IT GOES AGAINST THEIR
NARRATIVE.
AND THE WHOLE THING ABOUT WHAT
TUCKER CARLSON, HE HAD SOME
WORDS ABOUT ME.
HAVE ME ON YOUR SHOW.
I'LL GO ON.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT YOU, NOT
TO YOU.
>> I HAVE THE FEELING THAT GUYS
LIKE OFFICER DUNN, THEY'RE JUST
ANGRY, THEY'RE JUST UPSET THAT
NOT ONLY ARE WE SEEING RIOTERS
GETTING SLAPS ON THE RISK AND
TRUMP AND HIS ASSOCIATES TRYING
TO GET OFF SCOTT FREE.
BUT THIS DELIBERATE ATTEMPT ON
FOX TO WHITEWASH WHAT TOOK
PLACE.
>> YEAH.
FOX, THAT SHOW, TUCKER'S SHOW IS
DELIBERATELY DOING THAT.
IT'S NOT UNIVERSALLY DONE ACROSS
THE BOARD AT FOX, BUT THE TRUTH
IS, JIM, I CAN'T STAND WHAT
TUCKER IS DOING, BUT TUCKER IS
THE LEAST OF IT.
MOST REPUBLICAN PRIMARY VOTERS
AREN'T WATCHING FOX NEWS
ANYMORE.
THEY'RE ON O.A.N., NEWSMAX,
THEY'RE ON OTHER CHANNELS THAT
DEFINITELY AREN'T SHOWING HIM.
AND I WAS WITH A REPUBLICAN
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THIS WEEK WHO
TOLD ME THE MOST TRACTION SHE
GETS FROM HER VOTERS IS FROM
THOSE CHANNELS, THE OTHER ONES,
NOT FOX, AND FACEBOOK.
SO, I KNOW FOX IS IN THE WRONG
HERE.
BUT IT'S WAY WORSE THAN JUST ONE
NETWORK.
>> BUT IT'S CREATED THE
ECOSYSTEM.
AND THAT'S WHY -- LOOK, WE NEED
TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY RIGHT
NOW.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO PASS THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
THROUGH THE JANUARY 6th
COMMISSION TO HOLD RIOTERS
ACCOUNTABLE AND END ANY MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHO PLAYED FOOTSIE
WITH THIS STUFF.
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT LEAVE